today on the matt wall show i raised a
hundred thousand dollars for
aoc's grandmother and the money was
turned down as you can imagine i have
some thoughts to share about that we'll
do that today also five headlines
including blm
riots over their latest martyr again in
minneapolis this time this one was a
violent felon and fugitive who shot at
the cops
and then died in the process and yet
we're riding over him also
a prominent psychiatrist confesses her
fantasies of murdering white people
and she's a psychiatrist and a feud
between rival beekeepers has erupted on
tick-tock and you know i have to talk
about that plus our daily cancellation
and much more today on the matt wall
[Music]
show
out of all the headlines to come out of
the events of this past weekend this is
surely my favorite from the independent
it reads right wing blogger launches
gofundme for aoc's puerto rico
grandmother in latest personal attack
actually let me correct myself that's
not my favorite headline of the weekend
it's my favorite headline possibly of
all time and i feel that way even though
it misgenders me as a blogger which i'm
not
by the way not anymore um now now those
who who missed the show on friday
and uh and made the good and healthy
decision to avoid the internet over the
weekend are
no doubt extremely confused right now so
let me back up
and explain this story from the
beginning and then i'll talk about the
lessons that we can learn now that the
saga has reached its dramatic conclusion
so it began last week when congresswoman
alexandra casa cortez tweeted out
photographs of her grandmother's
dilapidated
home in puerto rico well allegedly her
grandmother's dilapidated home in puerto
rico
she explained that her dear abuela has
been living in this squalor with a
collapsing ceiling and buckets all over
the floor
to catch the rain water ever since
hurricane maria a few years ago
she explained that of course it's
trump's fault that nobody has bothered
to fix a boiler ceiling in the past four
years
now i responded to her tweet reminding
her that she's a wealthy and famous
politician and that maybe she should
take care of her own family members
using the funds that she has personally
available
to her as a wealthy and famous
politician
she responded to me she clapped back as
the
left-wing blogs put it saying that she's
worried about not just her grandmother
but the systemic injustices
in puerto rico and society in general
and she can accuse me of being
unconcerned
indeed totally fine with systemic
injustices myself
she did not however promise that she
would personally pay to fix
her grandmother's ceiling that was a
noticeable omission
in her response so a day later i
launched a gofundme campaign
to repair and save abuela's home
if aoc is not going to help her family
members and is going to wait around for
the government to fix the problem then i
felt it had fallen to me
to do what aoc would not or could not do
i'm not judging her though i just want
to be clear she did just buy a new tesla
and those monthly payments could be
pretty steep
she also has two apartments and she's
making payments on those so she's got a
money tied up and all that
and uh so you know i should probably
explain that to abuela and said listen
granny i'm sorry i got the two
apartments i got the tesla
you know you've got buckets right for
the rainwater you'll be fine just make
sure
you just you change those things out
every couple days
now right after starting the campaign i
of course reached out to aoc personally
both on twitter and through email
to try and coordinate with her to make
sure that the funds made it to her
abuela um she didn't respond to my
messages indeed she never publicly or
privately acknowledged the fundraiser at
all least of all did she thank me for it
i can't say i was surprised by that but
i also can't say that my feelings
weren't hurt
i'm a very sensitive and emotional guy
as you know
and uh that cut me pretty deep and yet
the fundraiser marched on
i wasn't doing this for personal
accolades
i was only partially doing it for
personal accolades mainly it was about
saving abuela's home and we made
stunning progress in that regard in the
space of just a few hours
many prominent people in right-wing
media including all of the hosts here at
the daily wire
as well as steven crowder and dave rubin
and others all joined the effort and
in this space of 10 hours get this
we raised 100 000
in 10 hours now think about that
100 grand in 10 hours aoc
couldn't apparently raise any money for
her abuela
in four years we raised a hundred
thousand dollars
in an afternoon on a friday
it was inspiring it was tremendous we
were
arguably the most successful charity
troll campaign of all time
it also might have been the only charity
troll campaign of all time
but then things took a turn around 10
o'clock on friday night
um i just got back from dinner with my
wife and i went to check
the gofundme page only to find that the
donations had been turned off
now it said on the page and this is what
confused me
it said that donations had been paused
quote by the organizer
but i thought i was the organizer and i
didn't pause them so that seems sort of
strange
then a short time later i received this
email from the gofundme trust and safety
team this is what i read
this is what it said i'll read it to you
it said and
pay close attention to the language they
use here
dear matt we are in touch with the
beneficiary's
family and they have made clear that
they will not be accepting the funds
raised
when a beneficiary doesn't want to
accept the funds that have been raised
on their behalf it is standard practice
to turn off donations
then refund all donors we recommend
posting an update on the fundraiser to
let your donors know that they will be
fully refunded within the next couple
days
they'll also receive an automatic
message from gofundme informing them
of their refund they will get 100 of
their donation back three to seven
business days after the refunds are
issued
please let us know if you have any
questions and they did issue the refunds
i
i put 499 dollars into the campaign to
kick things off
which happens to be the um the monthly
lease payment for tesla
you know we just chose that amount
randomly and um
i got the the refund yesterday i didn't
want it
i'm sorry abuela i tried as far as
questions i do have some
did abuela herself turn down the money
it says the beneficiary's family turned
it down but
we weren't raising money for her family
they have quite enough it would seem
like the tesla the two apartments you
know we were raising money for her
since when can the family the family of
a beneficiary
shut down a fundraising campaign and
more importantly why did they shut it
down
aoc showed us pictures of her abuela's
home
nearly falling apart by the looks of it
she was living in a crumbling shack and
had been living like that for years
we raised enough money to not only fix
her house but change her life and we did
that in 10 hours
imagine if we if it had gone on for
another two or three days
but we could have raised we could have
raised a million dollars
easily we could have and that could have
gone to
abuela and then they can then and and
they could have fixed up her home made
it perfect
and then they could have taken the rest
of the money if they wanted to because
it'd be their money
and they could have given it to a
charity in puerto rico to help other
people
they could we could have fixed up the
entire neighborhood
with that money and it was turned down
this is real money okay the money was
not a joke it's really there
the fact that someone in abuela's family
turned down the money
seems to indicate one of two things
either aoc would rather let her own
loved ones suffer
than accept help from conservatives and
not just her loved ones again
but the the whole community
the whole community could have benefited
from this
or and this is the other really
scandalous possibility
and i don't know if this is true or not
the other possibility is that she misled
the public
about abuela's living conditions were
those pictures
actually current photos of abuela's home
was it all a ruse
i don't know i mean she does seem to
have a history of
kind of exaggerating her own personal
trauma and perhaps that of those close
to her i don't know
maybe we'll never know but either way
whatever the explanation whatever
motivated the wayless family to shut
down the fundraiser while not saying a
word about it publicly the truth is
unflattering to aoc to say the least we
certainly exposed something through this
effort we could only speculate as to
what exactly that is
and honestly i am tired of aoc and
people like her
constantly using emotional blackmail and
supposed
personal trauma to score political
points in silence opposition
we called her on at this time in a big
way and i can guarantee you she regrets
ever bringing abuela into the
conversation if that's all we achieved
in the end
then i'd say it was more than worth it
but we achieved more than that
we proved another important point
tragedy and misfortune are often
exploited in order to push for
government action
and we're made to believe that the only
you know only the government
can address these sorts of problems
but we addressed the problem and could
have solved it
in just one day through private action
and i i have to keep stressing i cannot
stress enough
a hundred thousand dollars in 10 hours
we could have gone to a million
easily and how far could that money have
gone
not just for abuela but for the whole
community
if they had chosen to share it
there's a lesson here for those who are
willing to learn it
finally most of all we proved
that i am one of the world's leading
philanthropists
i'm like bill gates except without the
sex parties
or the 100 billion dollars so i guess
i'm not like bill gates at all come to
think of it but
i will now be throwing my hat into the
ring for a nobel peace prize i'm not
sure if that's how it works exactly but
i would like to announce that
i'll accept the award if it's offered to
me and i think we can all agree that i'm
deserving especially because
the award means absolutely nothing these
days anyway so you might as well give it
to a guy who trolled a politician by
raising a hundred thousand dollars for a
grandmother
why not now some people i know
uh are may not be satisfied and there
are still questions about what we did
here
and why we did it there are some even on
the right who object there were some on
the right who were offended by all of
this
and let me know it and there are some
people still questioning
you know was it all just a big troll was
it a stunt
was it charitable was it proving a point
was it trying to solve a problem
was it a sincere attempt to raise money
for a cause
was it mean was it nice was it petty was
it generous
was it hilarious the answer in short
is yes now let's get to our five
headlines
now word from our good friends over at
charity mobile look charity mobile is
the pro-life phone company and uh
they're probably a phone company because
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
which is which is great because it shows
that at least there's one company
they're not the only one but it's
unfortunately a minority of companies
out there that really are
on our side in the culture and fighting
for the same causes that we are and when
you find a company like
that it really is important to support
them you can help to build a culture of
life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company it's really a
win-win
both on the charity side of it and also
on the on the quality of the service
because
a lot of perks come with being a charity
mobile customer you get new activations
and eligible accounts get a free cell
phone with free activation and free
shipping
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees and there's no risk
with a 30-day guarantee
it's also a live customer service based
right here in usa and if you
have any issues at all need to talk to
them it's very easy to do
you can call them at 1-877-474-3662 or
chat with them
online at charitymobile.com again if you
want to be a charity mobile customer
chat with them online at
charitymobile.com also new lower monthly
plan prices and a new plan with higher
data limit
existing customers automatically get the
new lower plan prices so no need to
contact them
and ask again that's charitymobile.com
all right uh this is not in the my
headlines because i didn't watch it
because i'm not going to pay 50 for
something that you can watch after the
fact for free but
i guess there's this fight um boxing
match between
floyd mayweather and and uh and um
logan paul yesterday and i i guess
nobody won it was an exhibition match
there was there was no winner
um floyd mayweather is retired and in
his 40s
so he's got but he's also a professional
boxer logan paul
much bigger younger not a professional
boxer so you know you
match those two up and you get just a
bad fight i guess
that people paid 50 to watch
my only i guess my only question that i
that i take from uh this event and
really any boxing match but
you know you look at some of the
promotional photos
from this event and there's always that
one and because they always do this in
boxing where they
they you know square off a couple days
before the fight and they get
right in each other's like this close to
each other's faces
like they're like they're just about to
kiss with their mouths like
an inch from from each other and they
stare at each other for five minutes
and i feel really uncomfortable just
seeing it
i can't imagine how uncomfortable it is
to do
well i guess my point is why do what's
the point of that why do boxers do that
they don't do that they don't do that
before a football game
you don't have the players from both
sides take their helmets off
and meet in the middle of the field and
make out like that that only is in
boxing and i i don't understand it
that's the end of my analysis of that
all right um number one rioting broke
out in minneapolis again over the
weekend
it happened so often now especially in
minneapolis that you don't even notice
anymore of course part of the reason you
don't notice it is that the media
doesn't really cover it
and they don't cover it because for
obvious political and ideological
reasons but i also think
that it's it's hardly even news anymore
because it happens so often not to give
the media an excuse for not reporting
because they should
but at the same time i think everyone
almost has the same attitude
of uh oh yeah blm is riding again what
else is new
oh they burn down three buildings they
do do it all the time at a certain point
it just becomes part of the
the background um and it shouldn't be
but that's what it becomes because
they're allowed to do this over and over
again
for months and years on end um but
that's what was happening and this time
the martyr of choice is a guy named
winston bougie smith
as far as you know boujee is his real
middle name it's not a nickname
i could be wrong about that but this is
from fox9 let me read a little bit of
the
report to too it says winston bougie
smith as identified by family and
friends was shot by a ramsey county
deputy and a hennepin county
deputy during an encounter on the top
floor of the parking garage in the 1400
block
of lake street thursday afternoon um
a u.s marshal's fugitive task force was
attempting to arrest smith
32 years old for a want for a warrant on
a felony firearms violation when the
incident occurred
um bca investigators that's the bureau
of criminal apprehension
say there's evidence showing that smith
fired his gun from inside the vehicle
and spent casings were found on the
driver's side however there's no body
camera footage or squad dash cam footage
of the incident
the bca says members of the task force
weren't allowed to wear body cameras
despite a change in policy at the
federal level
allowing for the use of cameras by
officers and deputies on the task force
at the same time
social media postings seemed to show
smith was prepared for a confrontation
with police an internal document from
law enforcement quote smith as saying
quote
that he would quote shoot it out if he
was ever pulled off
um by law enforcement okay so
i mean that's really all you need to
know that
he he was a wanted felon
fugitive from justice that they were
pursuing
he had a gun this was not an unarmed in
no way was this an
unarmed man getting shot by cops he had
a gun he had an illegal gun because he's
a felon and a fugitive and you're not
allowed to have guns when you're a felon
in a fugitive
um and he shot he used it he was
shooting
at the police the the spent shell
casings
in the car pretty well confirms that
so a wanted fugitive violent felon
armed resisting arrest
and putting all that aside you know even
all of that doesn't matter
like the only thing that really matters
here is that he was shooting at the
police
and he got shot
literally any if you shoot at the cops i
don't care who you are
it doesn't matter if you're not a felon
you could be the greatest guy to work
you could be mr rogers
um shooting at the cops and you're gonna
get shot
perfectly fair in fact we could go even
further than that
like you shoot at anyone who has a gun
and you're going to get shot
legally
but so that's all you really need to
know about this
and that on top of the fact that he had
previously announced his intention to
shoot it out with the cops and then he
did shoot it out with the cops
but we could we could add some more
information he also had
i think it was 20 arrests under his belt
um including and he had
previously online had encouraged not
only had he announced his intention to
shoot it out with the cops
an intention which he then followed
through on but he had encouraged
the burning of police stations
he was encouraging violence against
police officers and then he went and
committed that violence himself
but one of his arrests and i almost
don't need to tell you this because
you know this is coming i'll let you
fill in the blanks
because there's one thing we know about
blm martyrs
almost in almost every almost every time
they are violent felons
in the process of resisting arrest and
assaulting or trying to kill cops
and what's what's one crime
one type of crime that they almost
always have committed
in the past violence against women right
so many cases of that whether it's
george floyd jacob blake etc
um and that was the case here too
winston bougie smith had 20 arrests
aggravated robbery of a woman being one
of them and i believe the woman was his
like his ex-girlfriend or something
he committed aggravated robbery against
her
it really is it's almost it's an
impressive track record
with blm every single
martyr that they choose ends up being
not only a violent felon but someone
specifically who had committed violence
against women
this is so common it's like they're
they're sifting through all of the
potential
martyrs that they can choose and it's
almost like they intentionally choose
the ones
who have committed some kind of violent
act against a woman
either it's an intentional choice or
it's a hell of a coincidence
that at this point you you you can
assume it
when blm is rioting over someone being
shot by the cops you could
before you even know the person's name
you can just assume that they've
committed some violent act against a
woman in the past because
that's it's always the case
all right let's go here if this is from
the new york post it says a
new york city-based psychiatrist told an
audience at the yale school of medicine
in april that she had fantasies of quote
unloading a revolver into the head of
any white person that got in my way
this is again the psychiatrist saying
this not one of her patients
i'd like to know what this psychiatrist
would say to a patient
who confesses these violent fantasies i
guess she would say
oh yeah me too that's completely natural
and normal
uh dr aruna kelani kilani we'll just
call her
spewed the race-hating virtual remarks
in which she also said she'd walk away
from the shooting with a bounce in my
step and that white people make my blood
boil
and are quote out of their minds and
have been for a long time
she said all that at the ivy league
institution's child study center
on april 6th audio of the talk which
we'll play in a second was posted on the
substack online platform of former new
york times opinion writer and editor
barry weiss
on friday along with an interview of
kilani conducted by writer and podcaster
katie herzog
a flyer promoting the talk and posted
online by weiss titled the lecture
quote the psychopathic problem of the
white mind
and included learning objective
objectives such as
set up white people's absence of empathy
towards black rage as a problem
and understand how white people are
psychologically dependent
on black rage what the hell does any of
that mean i have no idea but we have
some of the audio from the talk
and maybe that'll be explained in this
let's listen
why people make my blood boil around
five years ago i took some action
i systemically systematically i'm gonna
do it
right roasted most of my white friends
and i got rid of a couple white bipods
that
nothing my clue to i stopped watching
the news
once i started i couldn't stop i had
less than one percent left
it was also public service i had
fantasies of us loading a revolver into
the head
of any wet person that got in my way
gearing their body
and wiping my bloody hands as i walked
away relatively differently
with a bounce on myself now i have no
idea why it sounds like that audio was
recorded on a
with a toaster oven or something but uh
you can you can hear her say it there
and one thing is not that this really
matters at all but
from her her tone of voice and
everything it's it sounds to me like
these are prepared remarks
so when you first hear about this you
think okay was this an off the cuff
thing
and she was having a bad day and
she said this she was having a she like
a psychotic break in the middle of
not that i would excuse it but you think
maybe that's what happened no this
this seems like prepared remarks which
when you think of the title of the talk
is the psychopathic problem of the white
mind
i mean there's some irony there right oh
the white mind is psychopathic
not you you're talking about fantasizing
about blowing their brains out
for their race uh but these are prepared
remarks
it seems like so she she typed this out
she sat there and typed out uh yes i
have a fantasy of unloading a revolver
in the head of any white person that
gets in my way
and she feels what does this tell you
not only that
we have a psychiatrist
speaking obviously with some prominence
she's speaking at uh
to an audience at the yale school of
medicine so she's in a teaching capacity
as well
but a psychiatrist who feels this way
personally
what does that tell you and what does it
tell you that she feels so comfortable
talking about this and sharing these
viewpoints
she she knows now there was obviously at
least one person listening who didn't
approve and that's why they
took out their toaster oven and recorded
it but
she she knew that almost everyone in the
audience would agree with her
white or not
this isn't this isn't um mild
anti-white racism which will be which
would be bad enough
okay this isn't like i get annoyed at
white people sometimes
this is i want to kill them i fantasize
about
murdering them and i would walk away
with a
bounce and i would be happy
if you've ever had a fantasy like that
really fantasized about about actually
killing some
blowing someone's brains out
and you felt that you would be happy
after doing it
then you've got some deep spiritual and
psychological problems
i don't really care who the person is
but you're having this fantasy about an
entire race of people
this is like genocidal murderous
bigotry and and racist rage that she has
towards an entire group of people
and and these are also people how many
actual white people
have gone in to consult this
scumbag this racist scumbag
how many white people have have been
lying on the couch there consulting her
while she's just seething with rage
maybe eyeing the revolver she has locked
in the corner of the room and thinking
is this the time
should i do it now
this is really disturbing needless to
say
i would hope it's needless to say um
but what we have to understand is that
this stuff
and i think this isn't discussed enough
it's discussed by me but i don't think
it's discussed even by conservatives and
discussed in the general cultural enough
that this stuff is deeply ingrained in
the psychiatry and psychology fields
critical race theory gender theory all
of this
far left militant
radical leftism deeply ingrained in
these fields now we hear as
conservatives we know about the crt and
gender theory and everything
in the schools we know it's a problem
there in academia we talk about how it's
a problem in media
but it is probably even more deeply
ingrained
in the psychiatry and psychology fields
and
these are people who
have access to very vulnerable minds
they've got patients coming in who
that's why they're there they're
mentally vulnerable
and now they're being subjected to
brainwashing
from these militant wackos
that's why and people don't like it when
i say it but this is why i would be
very very wary of consulting a
psychiatrist or a psychologist
at all i'm not saying you can't trust
any of them i'm not saying you should
never
you should never consult them i'm just
saying i'd be wary i'd be
very cautious about it
and you got to really do your due
diligence before you pay these people
hundreds of dollars to hear your
problems
some of them a good number of them are
not just
far left wackos but are this is pure
evil
and once again the pure evil that she
felt perfectly comfortable
expressing to a room of her peers
comfortable for a good reason because
most of them feel the same it's the same
way
so i don't know if i if you were
thinking you needed to see a
psychologist a psychiatrist before you
if i were you before i did it i would
i'd be doing a lot of research i would
be talking
i'd be getting referrals i'd find
someone i trust who's already
met with that person and i would talk to
them to get some insight first
you just got to be very careful same
same
same way we should be very careful you
know what school you send your kid to
because this stuff is is there and is so
deeply ingrained in the school system
all right number three this is the new
york from the new york post it says a
texas mom
was arrested for allegedly posing as her
13-year-old daughter for nearly a whole
day of middle school
according to a report casey garcia
allegedly slipped into the unnamed
school in san
elizario dressed as the teen as her own
daughter complete with a hoodie a
backpack and a face mask
to prove a point about lack security
during the bizarre stunt nobody noticed
that she wasn't her daughter until the
seventh period at the end of the school
day
i think we have a video from the very
clip at the very end of this video she
posted on youtube after she got caught
and so she went through the entire day
this is a grown woman
30 years old she was at middle school
filming herself the entire day as a 30
year old woman posing as a student and
nobody caught her
until seventh period and i think we have
that let's watch
well i finally got caught i told him
that i would go to the principal's
office so i guess we're gonna see what
happens
just wanna say thank you to all the
girls that helped me get to all of my
classes yesterday
i really really appreciate it i honestly
would have been discovered
way sooner if it weren't for you and if
you knew my secret and you kept it for
me
thank you so much for not saying
anything i honestly could have not made
it the entire day
as a middle school student without you
okay i'm disappointed i thought we were
gonna get a clip of her
actually being confronted by the
principal i thought we would get her
at the principal's office being lectured
for being 30
and not 12 as was previously assumed
um so a lot of questions come to mind
it's kind of bizarre i think i don't
know exactly what point i guess she says
her point was
it was about the lack security at the
school which
she does expose that is very concerning
that a grown adult who's not a student
could hang out there and and
even in the video she interacts with
teachers talks to them
she goes to her classes she's sitting in
the lunchroom walking the hallways and
nobody notices
so there is something to be said there
about the lack security but i i think
what this is really a story about it's a
story about the face masks
that these kids are still in many
schools especially and where was this in
california
um in many schools these kids are still
being forced to wear
the face masks for no reason
the pandemic is over by the way
okay we we got through that the pandemic
is over
and um no reason to be wearing the face
mask
for all the reasons we've discussed
there never really has been a good
reason for kids to wear them considering
kids are not a high-risk group
but they're still forcing kids to wear
the face masks and
what that means is that the adults and
the teachers the people that are in
charge
they don't even know who these kids are
they can't identify who any of these
people are walk in the hallways
that's how you end up with a grown woman
sitting in the classroom
all day and nobody notices
what does that tell you about the face
mask thing
think about it there there are kids
most of these teachers now um
don't know what their own students look
like
think about how insane that is that's
why they can't differentiate a student
from a 30 year old woman
so i think she did make a valuable point
about the face mask i don't i don't know
if that
she intended for that to be her primary
point but that's the point she made
all right before we get to reading the
comments i have to talk about this uh
because it's
it is a story tailor made for me in so
many ways because it involves tick tock
and you know i love tick tock
and it also involves beekeeping um which
you know that's a passion of mine even
though i currently right now don't keep
any bees because we moved and i couldn't
bring the bees with me but still
i'm a beekeeper in my heart i think so
this is from nbc news it says a tick
tocker has gone viral for accusing a
beekeeping influencer
a beekeeping influencer i love that
that's a title that people
have now and that's what i wish i'm not
a blogger
okay independent i'm a beekeeping
influencer so next time
make sure you put that in your headline
a tick ticker has gone viral for
accusing a beekeeping influencer of
misleading viewers about how she handles
bees and for promote promoting bad
practices when when handling a hive
tick tock user la honeybee rescue claims
that erica thompson
who goes by texas b works on tick tock
and has 6 million followers is
improperly handling bees in her videos
and setting a dangerous precedent so
this is uh this is a really popular
thing on tick tock apparently a lot of
people watch these beekeeping videos
and we'll show you one just as an
example here's erica thompson um
a very popular beekeeper on tiktok had
no idea that was a thing but it is
and um let's watch one of the videos and
then we'll talk about the problems with
it
i got a call to remove bees from one of
the weirdest places ever
this toilet the bees had been living in
the tank of this toilet for years and
they filled the entire space with comb
and had no room left to grow
so i got to work removing the hive
everything i removed from the original
hive was safe for the bees to have in
their new home
here's what the comb looked like this
piece had honey at the top
pollen below and brood on the bottom i
spent a lot of time carefully removing
each piece of comb
this was a happy and healthy colony of
honeybees and they were not stinging me
at all
after i removed all of the comb the
toilet was still full of bees which told
me the queen was in there
suddenly i saw her crawling up the side
of the tank i put her in a clip to keep
her safe and i placed her in the new
hive
then i made a little bee bridge that led
straight to the queen so the bees could
easily get to their new hive
it worked and the bees marched right in
after the bees started to recognize the
bee box as their new home
i closed up the hive i waited for the
colony to move into the box
then we drove home and it was another
great day of saving the bees
okay so she followed good good proper
protocol there
i will say and by the way it'd be it
would be a hilarious prank for someone
to actually sit on that toilet not
knowing it's filled with bees of course
the toilet's outside and there's bees
buzzing all around it so i guess you'd
probably know
ahead of time but there are some
problems okay far be it for me to
criticize
but she's handling the beast she's not
just have any safety equipment on at all
and in fairness people that are very
experienced beekeepers a lot of times
they won't wear all of the equipment you
know the whole beekeeping suit and all
of that that's
beginners will wear all of that once you
get more comfortable you don't wear all
the equipment
because for one thing these are b's are
very docile especially if you use the
smoker
um which makes them even more docile and
as long as you're careful they probably
won't sting you
and things like the gloves like a lot of
people you feel like you want to wear
the gloves because you're handling bees
but um you're doing you're you know
doing a lot of sort of fine motor skills
and everything and you're picking things
up
and one of the ways to get yourself
stung is to drop something and scare the
bees and sometimes the gloves can make
it harder to
if you're handling comb or something or
frames it could make it harder to handle
them so you'll take the
gloves off but she's not wearing any
equipment at all and also she's wearing
dark
clothing and you notice beekeeping suits
are always white
why is that because dark clothing for
whatever reason that ticks off the bees
i think that maybe they confuse you with
a predator bear or something
and they go into attack mode so that's a
no-no you don't wear dark clothes she's
wearing nothing but dark clothing and
she also has her hair down
you know very and it looks it looks nice
and pretty but the problem is that the
bees get caught up in your hair and then
they start stinging your neck and your
face and everything
so not proper procedure and now we have
the
the critic of that beekeeper and this is
where the feud really begins let's
listen to her criticisms
all right this is for those of you who
had something to say about what i said
about texas b works
doing dangerous um
this is my job i do this for a living
and
i just had bees get through my hood
sting me all over the face when i was
35 feet up in that tree and um
i don't know if you noticed but texas b
works doesn't carry ladder she doesn't
carry power tools
her husband does all of that and then
sorry there's bees crawling up inside my
clothes right now
um poses her in situations not the ones
that are
at her avery apiary rather
that's hers she is a bee keeper but
she's not a bee removal specialist
and a guy in texas just died
by mowing his lawn next to a hollow tree
that had an africanized hive in it
because in texas
the bees are much more dangerous than
they are here so what she does is
dangerous
there you go see if you thought that
ufos
was kind of weird and niche content that
isn't interesting to
a lot of people in the audience you
haven't seen anything yet okay
get me going on bees and i'm really
gonna
i'm really gonna start boring you to
death um but i have to side with the uh
this is look there's a lot of drama in
the beekeeping community people don't
realize it
things get pretty intense even deadly
you never know but i kind of agree with
your criticisms
you know you don't want to send the
wrong message although at the same times
like you don't want to send
the wrong message about about improper
safety practices but at the same time
how many people are actually going to be
tempted because they watched a tick tock
video
to go and handle a beehive people tend
to be way more afraid of bees than they
should be which is which is
that's where people fall they tend to be
more afraid than they should be which is
fine
so i don't know maybe we need to talk
about it for another 20 minutes
and really get to the bottom of this or
we can move on to reading the youtube
comments
uh this is from the underdog says
arrest the criminals put them in prison
and keep them there uh for murderers yes
for rapists yes for weed smokers no
smoking weed shouldn't be a crime
well first of all you're already getting
what you want on that that's being
decriminalized everywhere
eventually it will be decriminalized
literally everywhere in the country
and it's it's not an issue i've ever
cared all that much about
but i guess i tend to agree um for the
most part
i i reluctantly i feel like i'm forced
to agree
my heart for weed to remain
illegal but i can't quite intellectually
justify it
and i think the argument made by uh
supporters of that position
that well weed isn't any more dangerous
than alcohol it isn't any more of us of
a social problem than alcohol
um in fact you know it's more dangerous
it kills a lot more people and alcohol
is legal so how do you justify having
this be
illegal i think it's a pretty solid
argument
um of course the argument could go the
other way and then you could say well
okay let's just let's just make alcohol
illegal too that's not my position to be
clear
so i tend to be persuaded by that
um although i also don't think this idea
that there were
the ways it's been presented by
advocates it's like as if they've just
been
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people in in prison
you know for years wasting away and all
they did was smoke a joint or something
i don't think that was ever
quite the case but uh i generally would
agree with you
um jacob says lol matt doesn't know the
psychoactive chemical in shrooms
yeah i i don't is that an lol thing is
that a general
a thing that most people know well
i guess so mr coo says hey matt if the
alien report comes out when you're on
vacation you may just have to bring back
the car podcast that's a very good idea
and you know what i
i promise you if the alien report comes
out when i'm on vacation
i will have something to say about it
probably from my car
because we're gonna be in a vacation
home with a lot of kids and i won't be
able to do it there
um another comment says matt if aoc
turns down the gofundme money can a
portion be donated to my family so we
can buy a decent car
my life has been a continuous fight with
old automobiles and their endless
problems and expenses for years in spite
of efforts to maintain them properly
just thought i'd ask well i appreciate
you asking first of all you could have
maybe aoc because she just bought a
tesla maybe she could help you out
um i've got a lot of messages like this
from people
some more serious than others i think
this is a little bit less serious i've
got a lot of messages
for people begging me for the money
saying hey if aoc doesn't want to please
give it to me
just so you know it doesn't work that
way with gofundme even if gofundme
hadn't shut down the account
you can't raise all the money and then
say yeah never mind i'm gonna give it
over here instead
that was never really an option what
happens is they shut it down and now all
the money is refunded
and that's it and we have no control
over that um
and finally how are you afraid of
spiders but would be excited to see
aliens from space come to our planet
well because aliens are from space
and spiders are from hell and i think
there's a difference there
now check it in with rock otto you know
i don't maybe you'll disagree with me
but my
idea of a good time doesn't really
involve shopping
in any store at all um but especially
not an auto parts store
if you're having car trouble and you're
walking around the auto parts store
looking for what you want to find and
you're not going to find it you got to
go ask the guy at the desk and then he's
going to ask you a bunch of questions
about your car you might not know off
the top of your head then you're going
to feel emasculated and you're going to
run out in tears
okay it's happened to me many times um
just cut out all of that and go
to rockauto.com pull out your phone
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear
and they're a family business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years and so they know really
know what they're doing and they know
how to set up
you know a catalog that is extensive has
everything you could possibly want but
also it's really easy to navigate
um so if you want to if you have car
trouble and you need
auto parts go to rockauto.com right now
you can see all the parts available for
your car truck remember as always to
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you if you've
watched uh
our new show with candace owens then you
know it's a great show and it's it's
great to watch
but uh you could also get it on the go i
don't know if you knew that
whether she's asking donald trump
hard-hitting questions like hopping on
his ticket in 2024
getting adam corolla to expose hollywood
conservatives or giving feminism the
roast it deserves with her panel of
guests
you're always guaranteed a smart and
funny listening experience so
uh don't just watch the show on
dailywire.com you can also subscribe to
and download candace the audio podcast
on apple spotify or wherever your
platform whatever your platform
platform of choice happens to be and if
you like what you hear be sure to leave
a five star review to keep candace's
podcast at the top of the charts
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation i have
uh not so much a specific person to
cancel as an attitude
and this begins with a viral tweet
thread which has since been deleted i'm
not going to name the user put it out
there originally because
that doesn't matter it was a random
small account but
the content perfectly reflects the
attitude that i want to address and it's
an attitude that's quite common
especially in the younger generation
these days the tweet said congrats on
graduating what's next
well just working a 40-hour work week
every week for the rest of my life being
completely unfulfilled and exhausted and
only having 6 p.m to 11 p.m to actually
relax and
being too exhausted to can be myself and
enjoy my hobbies only two days a week
then she went on with this line of
complaint for a while saying how
horrible it is that she's now graduated
and has to
be in the real world including this part
she said
i've had boomers tell me manage your
time better get a better schedule wake
up earlier
fu i'm mentally ill time doesn't exist
to me
i confess i was not previously aware of
a mental illness that turns you into a
transdimensional being who exists
outside of time
but i'm sure that's probably in the dsm
somewhere because everything else is
anyway this criticism of the standard
9-5 40-hour workweek
is as i said pretty pretty pretty
standard uh it's lots of people
especially younger people feel this way
and i suspect it's one of the reasons
that there's a shortage of workers right
now
which is crazy when you think about it
because last year we saw a record number
of jobs lost
record number i mean millions of people
losing their jobs
this year as things are opening up again
somehow companies are having trouble
finding people willing to take the
positions they're offering
now obviously that has plenty to do with
the fact that our government is paying
people to stay home
but it's also indicative of this general
idea believed by many people
that normal jobs are beneath them not
worth their time
they are owed something more than that
better than that
they don't want to be one of the rubes
out there in the rat race punching the
clock making them easily paycheck and so
on
now to begin with we should say that
40 hours a week just so you know and i
don't mean to scare you
if you're just getting out of high
school or college right now
um getting into the the working world 40
hours a week
isn't that much if you only work from
nine to five and you don't have to bring
your work home with you and you always
get your weekends off
then consider yourself blessed nine to
five
that's the bare minimum in terms of
full-time employment
if you worked a few hours fewer than
that it wouldn't even count as a
full-time job anymore
so if the horrible grind of having to be
at work by 9 a.m
is causing you to break out in hives and
tremble with terror
your problem is probably just that
you're extremely lazy
also it must be said that
working a 9 to five or an eight to six
or you know
seven to seven or or whatever your hours
are
even if it's in a job you don't feel
especially passionate about
is a noble endeavor because you're
fulfilling your responsibilities
you're taking care of yourself and
you're taking care of your family
now it's great if you can do something
for a living that you love
whether that fits into the nine-to-five
framework or not but many people work
their whole lives in jobs they don't
love
are they wasting their time see we look
down on that these days we say oh
that's you know you shouldn't do
something you don't you don't want to do
you're wasting your time
no i mean did they squander their human
existence by spending so much of it
doing something they don't like
no not at all because for them the job
is a means to an end
the end is supporting their families and
themselves they might not find a lot of
purpose and meaning in the nature of the
job itself
but they can find purpose and meaning
outside of the job
which is a really good place to look for
it by the way no matter what you do for
a living
and that's perfectly fine and it's
meaningful and it's an honorable way to
live
so the young people just graduating who
think they're too good
too interesting too important to punch
the clock like everybody else
what i would say is this get over
yourself princess
you haven't done anything notable with
your life yet you have no skills you
have no experience
you haven't earned the right to think so
highly of yourself
but what about people who not through a
sense of self-importance but due to
their own unique
passions and preferences would simply
prefer to do something different with
their lives would like to go a different
way
rather than becoming an employee for
some company and putting in their 40 or
50 hours every week
well to those people i say go for it
blaze your own trail
strike out on a different path take a
risk
maybe you could start your own business
become an entrepreneur
maybe you could become a writer maybe
you could start your own podcast i have
one it can't be that hard right
maybe you could start a self-sustaining
farm out in the country
maybe you i don't know become a wildlife
photographer or something
i know a guy who left his job and became
a fishing guide so he spends all his
time now out in the woods in streams and
lakes
fishing and teaching other people about
fishing he's living the absolute dream
maybe you could try to do that maybe
you'd like to travel and figure out a
way to earn a living while you do it i
know a few people have done that
maybe you burn your social security card
and driver's license and set off for
alaska on foot like the guy from uh into
the wild
now granted he ended up dying out there
but maybe you'll have better luck or
maybe not
maybe you can become a professional
beekeeper and get involved in all that
trauma
maybe you have a real skill in the arts
or athletics i met someone a couple
years ago
who goes around making ice sculptures
and selling them
maybe you could do that there are an
endless array of options you could do
almost anything or try to do almost
anything anyway
but the chance of failure with any of
the options i just listed is very high
in fact
most of the people who do the things i
listed or similar things end up failing
it's high risk high reward and the cost
of failure can be steep
what happens when you find yourself in
vietnam and you realize that nobody
cares about the travel blog that was
supposed to
finance your trip what happens when you
self-publish your novel you took a year
to write
and it sells literally 14 copies like
most books do
by the way it could be a disaster
but that's the risk you take and it
could be worth the risk
so i say again go for it do it try
something different you're young you
have no dependence presumably
you have only yourself to care for if
things go sideways and you end up
sleeping in your car for a few months
well
it's not gonna be fun but it's doable so
go ahead be bold be daring
try to do something with your life where
when other people tell when you tell
other people your plans
they look at you sideways and go okay
you're going to try to make a living
doing that
then maybe actually you do make a living
doing it and you get the enjoyment of
hearing that same person
10 years from now tell everybody how
they always believed in you
or maybe you fail miserably and you get
the enjoyment of hearing that same
person say i told you so
who knows what will happen but you never
know until you try
but see all of these alternative paths
require work a whole lot of work
in fact oftentimes much more work much
much more work than the nine to five
which again is not that much work
so you're not getting out of work this
way you may be getting out of having a
job
but you don't escape work there is no
escaping
work life is work and the problem is
that a significant portion of the young
people who complain about the nine to
five
are really complaining about work they
don't want to do any work
of any kind at all they gravitate to
socialism because they wish to do
nothing they
to wish to exert no effort and have all
of their needs met
and not just their needs they want to
have all of the material luxuries of
life along with it
they're anti-capitalist anti-work
but still materialist it is a confused
contradictory and unsustainable way to
be
the dream of living a luxurious pampered
life without work
it's even less realistic than making a
living as a traveling ice sculptor
i mean a few people in the history of
the world have lived that way children
of billionaires
and children of royalty mainly i mean
those are that's basically it
but for you it's probably not an option
and
here's the thing even if it was it
wouldn't be worth it
you want to talk about a life that's not
worth living a life without work
some kind of work is not worth living
there's a reason why jackpot lottery
winners rarely live happily ever after
you hear these stories
often they wind up on drugs divorced in
prison
dead shortly after the big win they were
given all the material
rewards life has to offer but they
hadn't earned any of it
they took the shortcut and made it to
the other side and then when they got
there they had no idea what to do so
they opted for heroin and hookers
you cannot remove work from your life
and yet retain fulfillment and happiness
these are all of a piece again you don't
have to work for a company
on a payroll in order to be happy but
you have to do some kind of work
the guy from into the wild i mentioned
he made it out into the alaskan
wilderness
and then he ended up starving to death
and shortly before he died he
highlighted the words
happiness is only real when shared in a
book that was found
near his decomposing body and there's a
lot of truth to that
happiness is only real when shared and
it's the lesson that he learned but you
could just as well say
happiness is only real when earned
so if you want to have a happy and
fulfilled life and that's what everybody
wants in the end
then you have to work for it one way or
another
and so that is why that random girl on
twitter
is canceled and i don't know who else to
cancel will get to the end of this thing
so it's just gonna be her i guess
unfortunately
and uh we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show senator
joe manchin may be killing democratic
dreams like all together is the biden
administration over that's today on the
bench bureau show